PERHAPS SOMEWHERE MUCH BETTER.
JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS ALL OF
TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS,
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SARAH SANDERS.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
DOES THE PRESIDENT HAVE ANY
REACTION TO OCASIO-CORTEZ, THE
CONGRESSWOMAN'S PREDICTION,
MILLENNIALS THINK LIKE THAT,
WE'RE ARE LIKE THE WORLD IS
GOING TO END IN 12 YEARS IF WE
DO NOT ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE?
ANY OFFICIAL WEIGHT HOUSE
POSITION?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT WE ARE
GOING TO LISTEN TO HER ON MUCH
OF ANYTHING, PARTICULARLY ANY
THAT WE WILL LEAVE INTO THE
HANDS OF A MUCH, MUCH HIGHER
AUTHORITY.
AND CERTAINLY NOT LISTEN TO THE
FRESHMAN CONGRESSWOMAN ON WHEN
THE WORLD MAY END.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE WORLD RIGHT
NOW.
WE WISH THAT DEMOCRATS WOULD
ENGAGE IN THAT CONVERSATION AND
FIXED SOME OF THE CURRENT
PROBLEM THAT WE KNOW EXISTS AND
WORK WITH US TO GET SOME THINGS
DONE.
PARTICULARLY ON THE BORDER AND
FIXING THE NATIONAL AND
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE FOCUSED ON.
NOT THINGS WE WILL LEAVE UP INTO
THE HANDS OF SOMETHING AND
SOMEONE MUCH MORE POWERFUL THAN
ANY OF US.
>> Sean: LET'S GO TO THE ISSUE
OF THE SHUTDOWN WHERE WE ARE.
THE PRESIDENT MADE A PROPOSAL TO
THE DEMOCRATS, BY THE WAY, THEY
REJECTED IT BEFORE IT WAS EVEN,
SOME OF THEM REJECTED IT BEFORE
THEY KNEW WHAT WAS IN IT.
THESE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE THINGS
THAT THE DEMOCRATS LIKE,
DREAMERS, DACA KIDS, ET CETERA,
ON TOP OF 45 YEARS AGO THEY WERE
IN FAVOR OF BUILDING THE WALL
AND SOUNDED LIKE THE PRESIDENT,
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN OFFERED ONE
INVITATION AFTER ANOTHER, THEY
REFUSED TO SIT DOWN AND THEY
SEND AIDES AND SURROGATES
INSTEAD OF THEMSELVES SITTING
DOWN.
AT THIS POINT IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
PRESIDENT WILL HAVE TO JUST GO
IT ALONE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY NEWS ABOUT THAT
ON ANY FRONT?
>> LOOK AT, SEAN, I HOPE THAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO GO IT
ALONE.
ONE THING I HOPE IS THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN IN
LOCKSTEP WITH THE PRESIDENT,
BUT BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN
GETTING SOMETHING DONE.
THE FACT THAT DEMOCRATS WENT OUT
BEFORE THE PRESIDENT EVEN PUT
HIS PROPOSAL FORWARD ON SATURDAY
AND REJECTED IT, SHOWS EXACTLY
WHERE THEY ARE.
THAT IS THAT THEY ARE NOT
LOOKING TO SOLVE PROBLEMS, BUT
THEY ARE SIMPLY LOOKING TO KICK
THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD.
AND OBSTRUCT ANY PROGRESS BEING
MADE WHETHER IT IS ON THIS ISSUE
OR ANYTHING ELSE.
WE HAVE SEEN NO INDICATION THAT
THEY WANT TO WORK WITH THE
PRESIDENT TO FIX THE PROBLEMS
FACING THIS COUNTRY.
I THINK IT IS A SAD DAY IN
AMERICA WHEN NANCY PELOSI
PROJECTS AN IDEA BEFORE SHE HAS
EVEN HEARD IT.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, I THINK THAT
SHE IS SHOWING US EXACTLY WHO
SHE IS AND WHAT HER PRIORITIES
ARE.
THAT IS NOT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE ONLY PERSON IN THIS PROCESS
AND IN THIS BACK-AND-FORTH THAT
IS ACTUALLY DOING SOMETHING TO
HELP THE 800,000 FEDERAL WORKERS
THAT IS ACTUALLY STOPPING THE
OPIOID CRISIS, AND THE SECURITY
AT OUR BORDER IS THE PRESIDENT.
DEMOCRATS CLAIM TO CARE ABOUT
THESE PEOPLE AND CLAIM TO FIX
PROBLEMS, BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THEY WANT TO IGNORE THE PROBLEM
AND ATTACKED THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK THAT THAT IS A VERY,
VERY SAD DAY.
AND IT SHOWS US WHAT A LEADER IS
AND WHAT A LEADER ISN'T.
TO THE PRESIDENT AS A LEADER,
AND NANCY PELOSI IS NOTHING MORE
THAN AN OBSTRUCTIONIST.
>> Sean: LET'S GO TO THE
LATEST DATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS, WHERE ARE WE THERE?
>> NANCY PELOSI NANCY PELOSI
INVITED THE PRESIDENT, HE
ACCEPTED, SHE CITED SECURITY
CONCERNS AS A POTENTIAL REASON T
CONCERNS AS A POTENTIAL REASON O
DELAY THAT.
THE UNITED STATES SECRET SERVICE
AND DHS HAVE ADDRESSED THOSE
CONCERNS.
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD UNTIL
SOMETHING CHANGES ON THAT FRONT.
>> Sean: WILL THE PRESIDENT
CONSIDER OTHER OPTIONS IF THE
HOUSE IS NOT OPEN TO HER?
I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU WILL GET
135 MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND
INVITED GUESTS, YOU KNOW, IN
WASHINGTON.
I'M SURE THAT THERE IS A PLACE,
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT IS.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THERE WOULD
BE A PLACE THAT ALL OF THOSE
MEMBERS WOULD ATTEND, BUT THE
PRESIDENT FOCUSES ON SPEAKING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT HE DOES
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
NOBODY DOES IT BETTER.
AND IF NANCY PELOSI CHOOSES TO
GO IN THAT DIRECTION, THE
PRESIDENT WILL CONTINUE TO SPEAK
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND I'M SURE THAT HE WILL DO
THAT ON THAT EVENING AS WELL.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED FRIDAY WITH
BUZZFEED, AND IF IT IS TRUE, YOU
HAD LITERALLY EVERY MAJOR
NEWSPAPER, EVERY SINGLE NETWORK,
SO CALLED NEWS CHANNELS OVER 200
TIMES GO FOR IF IT IS TRUE AND
THEN SPEND HOURS AFTER HOUR
AFTER HOUR SAYING IMPEACHMENT
WITHOUT ANY VERIFICATION.
THERE WAS A LIST OF 67 MEDIA
MISTAKES IN THE TRUMP ERA, THE
DEFINITIVE LIST.
I PRINTED OUT LITERALLY 47 SMALL
PRINT PAGES OF THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER" OF
MISTAKES THAT THE MEDIA HAS MADE
IN THE REPORTING OF THE
PRESIDENT IN ONE YEAR ALONE.
THAT WOULD BE 2017.
HIS REACTION TO IT, AND THE
PRESIDENT'S BRANDING A FAKE
NEWS, IS THAT FOREVER ETCHED
INTO THE MINDS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHEN THEY SEE EVENTS LIKE
THIS ON FRIDAY AND FOLLOWED BY
COVINGTON AND WHAT HAPPENED TO
THOSE STUDENTS?
>> HONESTLY, SEAN, WE HOPE NOT.
WE HOPE THAT FAKE NEWS DOES NOT
BECOME THE FOREVER BRAND OF THE
NEWS MEDIA, BECAUSE IT IS NOT
GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID.
HE WOULD LOVE FOR PEOPLE TO
REPORT THINGS ACCURATELY.
WHAT HAPPEN WITH BUZZFEED IS A
GREAT LESSON FOR THE MEDIA.
QUIT TRYING TO BE FIRST AND
START TRYING TO BE RIGHT.
WE HAVE SEEN TIME AND TIME AGAIN
WHERE THEY RUN OUT HERE WITH
RIDICULOUS STORIES.
ONE PERSON REPORTS IT TO BEGIN
WITH AND THEY ALL JUMP ON IT.
WE SAW IT AGAIN WITH THE
COVINGTON STUDENTS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN PEOPLE SO HAPPY
TO DESTROY A KID'S LIFE.
WHEN THAT BECOMES THE NORM IN
THE MEDIA IN AMERICA SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS PRESIDENT, THAT IS
DISGRACEFUL.
THAT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
LET'S THAT THIS IS A LESSON TO